centenares de manifestantes en las
calles de mineápolis y municipios
aledaños de nuevo igual que hace casi un
año se incendió la ciudad por la muerte
del afroamericano georges floyd esta vez
las protestas denuncian la muerte de
donde wright un joven negro de 20 años
que murió por los disparos de un agente
blanca de policía la del lunes fue la
segunda noche de virulentas protestas a
pesar de que las autoridades han
decretado un toque de queda y de qué
mineápolis se encuentra bajo extremas
medidas de seguridad precisamente por el
juicio contra derecho ven el policía que
ahogó a georges floyd el presidente de
eeuu llamó a la calma
tenemos que esperar una investigación
completa
mientras tanto lo dejo claro no hay
ninguna justificación para los saqueos
ni la violencia
la policía de brooklyn center la ciudad
donde murió el joven raid hizo públicas
las imágenes del incidente
justo después la policía le apunta y le
dispara las autoridades indican de
manera preliminar que la gente confundió
su pistola taser con la de verdad las
imágenes de escalofriantes han encendido
todavía más los ánimos
ahora el mundo observa el juicio con la
policía de brooklyn center
para mostrar lo mortífera que es la
policía contra la gente de color mató a
un joven desarmado de 20 años
precisamente un nuevo testimonio volvió
a ratificar ante los tribunales que
floyd murió por asfixia en un juicio que
se vive como un veredicto sobre el
racismo en la sociedad estadounidense